so what we've seen is that latest belief
right so now it's sulfate familiar that
Creole languages emerged through these
abnormal bricks okay
structural brakes that according to many
linguists perhaps most linguists put
Creoles outside the realm of coat normal
languages you know and I have to insist
on the code because I don't believe that
okay I'm gonna say it up front I do not
believe that Creoles are to be excluded
from the realm of normal languages and
from your med card feedback its me that
yourself are feeling very unhappy with
this classification okay so what we're
doing now we're doing something very
which I hope is scientific looking at
the at the claims why do they imply for
the for the actual structures of Creoles
as I speak them as Karen's parents speak
them you know as real living systems and
so why do these claims mean for those
real languages that people actually
speak in the homes in the schools
etcetera okay so this is the basic
question right so all these current code
discontinuity is that we find in the
history of Creoles
are they deeply distinct from what you
find in the history of English okay and
this is what we were looking at last
time and then once we have the resource
of this comparison then we can ask so
what does that mean in terms of what we
should believe about Creole languages
okay so so this is just a summary of
what we discussed last week so what we
saw in that summary is that both in its
lexicon in its vocabulary but also in
terms of its syntax and we focus on one
particular aspect of of English syntax
having to do with where where you
pronounce the verb this IV the adverb
and with so many examples where English
has a very different order now than it
had in the mid in middle english like in
the 1415 century okay not only that we
also saw that English in a way has
broken the morphology the conjugation of
middle english so what what we see in
the history of English is a set of
of comparative facts that show that the
history of English in a way is very much
like the history of Haitian Creole as it
emerged from French in fact what we saw
is that if you look at the vocabulary of
English it's much more current called
Mok ironic it's a much more mixed
vocabulary in terms of word coming from
French from Latin from the languages as
compared to due to the vocabulary of
Creole Ovation Creole which is mostly at
least 90% French okay so on one hand you
have a creole language with the Korean
code well-behaved vocabulary where most
of the words come from one language and
on the other hand you have English which
is supposed to be a normal genetic
language that nobody disrespects in
which is the world language in a way it
wasn't a franca but yet English in a so
capillary is much more macaroni much
more misbehave in having words from all
over the world to speak so so what we
did conclude and we're going to actually
see more data that will support this
conclusion is that with respect to the
syntax and the morphology of verbs and
also in terms of its lexicon
there is no there is no key difference
between Equalization
as in the history of Asian Creole versus
language change as in the history of
English in fact if there is any
difference it could make English out
Creole Haitian Creole in we should be
there even more Creole in a particular
way than in Haitian Creole and now what
I want to show you very quickly is that
you know these facts come up in
throughout the grammar of English so so
here we can look at one other set of
facts are going to do with where you
pronounce pronouns object pronoun so I'm
going to give you some examples from
Haitian Creole so by now you should
BuChE BuChE me to be very familiar there
are there are folk characters in entails
and he shunted off that you know when I
was a kid I would listen to so buki
supposed to be like a kind of not very
smart character and then they spoke in
it which is its wife so so Buki corny
Buki net okay and then if you replace
book ended by a pronoun you say Mookie
okay now what's tracking here is
something which is as an English speaker
you would accept without hesitation
which is that the object whether it's a
name like booking net or whether it's a
pronoun like him or her or it it comes
after the verb you say Buki con le like
in English would say book he knows him
or book he knows her a book into it okay
and what you cannot have you cannot have
the the pronoun comes before this you
cannot say Buki Leone now if some of you
know French so if you know if you know
French you say well gosh no this is here
again
no Creole has broken this syntax or
friends because in French you know the
order in to Buki lacunae is what you get
in French you have this rule where if if
the object is a pronoun then you have to
move it to the left of the verb okay
this is what we get now you say Buki
Cohen a book net and you say Buki
lacunae so now the problem la is refers
to boogie net and it better come before
the verb
you cannot say Buki cornellà okay so
that's the way your birth contrast
between Cajun Creole and French what do
you wear do you pronounce the object we
need to pronoun okay so this is our
summary okay so in that some really
clearly where the differences are in
terms of not only the object pronoun but
also in terms of what we saw last week
in the last three rules in terms of
where you pronounce the the adverb
negation is that be the finite verb so
the fin is verb ferret you see so so
it's in both in these two cases what you
have here and there you have a reversal
of the order so in in Creole you have
verb pronoun in French have pollen verb
in Creole you have adverb verb in French
have verb adverb and then something else
that we saw is that it Creole and like
French
you have those suffixes are expressed as
pre verbal items from last time right
okay now what we're going to see now
going to see so one could ask so if you
look at so this particular pattern here
which is like what we saw earlier we are
the object so if this is the case
obviously you know I eat rice okay
so increasing ggv okay where you have
rice after the verb if you say I'm
eating rice you say Matt mochi GE so now
what we're going to see because remember
that theory about explication remember
the claims there so what's the clinic
that's right that's right
very good very good so that's a very
nice one sentence summary of this theory
right which is that so basically the
literal grammar is a mix between say in
the case of Haiti between French and big
grammar right so you take the words from
French and then the words I impose on
the grammar of an African language in
the case of Haiti to be the grammar of
the B okay so now what what one should
ask in the case of this particular order
that we saw is different from French we
could ask where is it come from
okay well maybe it comes from it comes
from the B languages because in fact in
bay you have this 8 v order you get you
do subject-verb-object where the object
is pronounced after the verb okay so
this is like here you see it rise you
know this is how you see I want try to
pronounce it because it's a tonal
language very complicated so I don't
know the tones but I have a colleague
that I wrote papers with
a bow and a knock speaks a gay language
ok so these are data from a knock it
rise very much like here okay
subject verb order so think of object
order but yet there is a twist and this
is where we cannot say that cruel
grammar is the
vacation of big ramen because in fact
like in French you do get all the order
in in in Creole in in bay okay
so you get you get it here right so when
you have an aspect show market meaning
that you go from saying and it rise to
I'm eating rice well you what to expect
a progressive the way you express a
progressive you have I and and something
like the verb to be and you get rice eat
right and then you have this other
market at the end right so so here you
can see clearly that this pattern in
Asian Creole is different both from
French and from from would be because
both French and they have o V or the
object verb order but Haitian claw
doesn't have that okay so this is just a
quick data point to actually show you
that those theories that either claim
that Haitian Creole is rectified from
from South African language and those
theories that claim that it's in Creole
is broken friends and tracks in to some
degree they're both actually inaccurate
so what we're going to do now going to
actually look of a case of language
change and when to go back to English we
actually find the same pattern we have
at some point in the history of English
we also had all the order and at a later
point this ovie order was lost
okay so and you can actually do it
pretty straightforwardly
using data so these are data from all
the English so what you see here this is
a sentence in Old English that could
express the this area of the permeance
told him many stories and what you have
to focus on here is the fact that the
pull on him is pronounced before told
write him so Minister is him told the
permeance and this is fine Old English
so if you are living in Mission the time
this is the way you would you would you
would say it it was very productive
right so here to you see that he would
give him fifteen thousand gold that he
had
gave you see where you have the pull on
him before the film okay now that should
ring a bell you know when it comes to
the history of efficient career because
again in in in French pretty much like
an old English you had you have a
similar pattern right so this is the
case where so if we take the same
examples in in English and you say it in
and you say it in in French yeah we have
a similar pattern where the object hem
is pronounced before the verb to tell so
he's guilty callused well you have gotta
go until you see you have me before I go
to ha
and then here this is similar examples
from the Old English envy Dona can't
live with or wait me the the him pronoun
is pronounced before the verb to give ok
so what is that telling us so it's
telling us that in fact pretty much like
what we show what we should before in
the history of the adverb verb pattern
that modern English like Asian Creole as
as soon as we a drastic change in world
order like you had before
adverb verb order arising from the Alpha
border in this case you have object verb
order making place for the object order
right so if we were to say that the
Haitian Creole broke the syntax of
French then you have to also claim that
English from the syntax of Old English
from your English and then you can see
that it doesn't make sense right so why
would one case be creation that supposed
to be abnormal change in the other cases
well it's just language change right and
in fact what we see is that even if you
look at the history of French in North
America you find similar patterns right
so so there are various varieties of
French that which are not called Creole
languages which are just called misery
French or with IANA French and what you
find in these varieties of French are
similar patterns where so again in
European French you would say it'll move
their home you would say
so so if you they will see me so here
you will say should to meet hey to
tumblr
this is Parisian French say where you
have the object comes before the firm in
those two patterns now or you would say
should interrogate and every where you
have the pronoun know which is which is
alighted as Lu coming before the verb
now I picked examples because I found
instances of these same patterns in
Cajun French and misery French where you
have a different order right so so here
you see you say Eve no pour moi this is
Cajun French and watch what striking is
that the the object pronoun moi is
pronounced after the verb even for what
actually there's another difference is
that the verb is the the non-finite form
you save wha which means like to see
it's not finite does it take agreement
on it all times the tensed expressed by
the verb that comes before that's like
it's like I will see you or I will see
me or they will see me you see where you
get the marker before the verb to
express the future and then you get the
object after the verb okay and the same
is true here
you know vomit we to tumblr again do the
key from here is the object pronoun
tweet which comes after met which is not
like European French it's very unlike
European French and here as well you
know my own tal then a three again L is
the pronoun it comes after the verb so
in all three of these patterns you find
something which is very cruel like right
but yet these are not call this because
like me generally is a Creole but this
is not the closest French this is Cajun
French this is misery French in the last
examples so what does that mean it means
then that that Cajun misery French black
jean-claude the exhibit is same sort of
patterns no where so we are European
French as objects verb order those
French varieties have the reverse
pattern
so so this is the the conclusion for now
is that so here too we have the clear
appearance of creel like patterns in in
those varieties which are not called
Creoles so it's pretty much the same
alchemy that's before that that you find
those those linguistic types of changes
in molecular energy so then what's the
what's the value of of positing that you
have particular changes that are
specifically Creole like a localization